astronomers tell us that when we look to
the night sky we're actually looking
back in time light from those far away
Stars takes so long to reach our eyes
here on Earth that by the time we wish
upon a particular star it may no longer
even exist I'm here to tell you the
population of Earth is a lot like those
stars in parts of the globe the human
population is already or will soon be
shrinking I know what you're thinking
and yes total population is still
growing from 8 billion today to a peak
of probably 9 or 10 billion but when we
track total increase we're looking at
this star that seems to be shining
brightly but in actuality has already
imploded and that's because there's a
difference between what's happening on
the surface which is obvious total
growth and the tectonic forces beneath
since the 1960s world population has
more than doubled but the growth rate
has been falling the entire time we are
witnessing the most fundamental shift to
take place in modern human history the
shift towards pervasive and permanent
low fertility population aging and
eventual
depopulation fertility is down
everywhere just at different rates in
different
places if fertility stays the same as it
is today just hold still by the end of
this Century China's population will be
less than half of its current size it's
a loss of 800 million people South
Korea's will be down by
63% Poland's and Japan by half Italy and
Thailand's by
44% Eastern Europe by
40% even greater number of countries are
already aging again just 20 years ago if
we'd lined up everyone in Japan or Italy
or Germany from the youngest person to
the oldest and we ask that person in the
middle their age they would have been 40
years old today the populations of
Thailand Kuwait and Cuba are just as old
with Chile Iran and Vietnam close behind
and even India as it seems to be this
bright star assuming the throne as
world's most populous country has below
replacement fertility the number of
young people entering into India's
Workforce has already
peaked people are the foundation of
everything in a society we're the
workers and the voters and the soldiers
and the caregivers so how many of us
there are and who we are that matters
we're on track for there to be more
people over age 60 than under the age of
14 by the middle of this Century that
radical shift in modern Human Society
presents us with a world of
possibilities our demography is our
destiny yes but how we react to that
demography is not pre-ordained
what possible worlds might we create if
we thoughtfully plan for an older
smaller
population in one possible world we put
our heads in the sand and keep going
about our business as usual we have seen
most societies react like they're living
in this world and throw money at people
to have more babies but it doesn't work
South Korea has spent $210 billion
dollar over the last 16 years trying to
raise fertility and they keep hitting
record lows under one child per woman on
average in this status qu world we keep
the same economic models that assume
infinite population growth and amass
more debt to pay for our public spending
our social safety nets stay the same
which those rely on more inputs from
workers than withdrawals from retirees
that's what we call a pay youo system
Western Europe is already struggling to
keep these systems afloat because in
many of those countries there are only
two workers for every retiree you can
see how topheavy the population's age
structure is here in how in the next few
years it will grow even more so that way
in a status quo world the world's most
powerful countries continue to increase
military spending and try to project
power beyond their borders even as their
National budgets strain and the
recruiting pool for soldiers
shrinks hello Russia China and maybe
even the United States so what results
from failing to adapt and clinging to
the status quo systems overload and
break we have higher labor costs which
lead to inflation and that just makes it
even more expensive to have children
social security systems go bankrupt and
we lose the gains we've made in reducing
old age
poverty but AE in the sand world isn't
as bad as a fearful one in a fearful
world the ability to choose how many
children to have and when to have them
gets taken away something that's easier
in less Democratic settings and not good
news here either 20 years ago almost all
of our aging countries were
democracies now a quarter of them those
with median ages of 35 or higher aren't
free and I know we see this idea of
coercion in science fiction but it's not
just science fiction in 1965 when
Nikolai chesu took the helm in Romania
and he wanted more Romanian babies he
forced it to happen through invasive
measures fertility temporarily spiked
but not without dire consequence quences
for women and for those children many of
whom were abandoned to
orphanages in a fearful
World immigration becomes more
restricted there's more hatred and
division as majority groups fear being
replaced by people who don't look like
them there's less Global cooperation as
aging shrinking C countries are they
lose the willingness and ability to
think about causes outside their borders
and fund those we can't come together on
pandemics or climate change or other
transboundary issues does any of this
sound
familiar I actually don't think we're
fully in this world yet even if way too
much of this hits close to home but I
can imagine how we might get there if we
aren't proactive to shape the world we
want and what kind of world would we
want well in a resilient world we
compete to attract Talent from across
the globe and set aside our nationalist
Tendencies a shrinking world is in our
future but obviously some places are
much closer than others uh in the
Democratic Republic of the Congo
Ethiopia Nigeria Tanzania fertility is
still high enough that each generation
is twice the size of the one before
it those young and growing populations
can be a tremendous resource for their
National economies if we have
investments in human capital and other
policies that can help these countries
reap a demographic
dividend and they can be a resource for
the global economy too I mean the US and
Canada they they stand out as still
growing despite below replacement
fertility in both and in fact Canada had
record population growth last year 96%
of which was due to
immigration there aren't the only models
for immigration and there are obvious
trade-offs to opening your borders but
no one said this would be easy and
speaking of things not being easy we're
going to have to work longer me too you
too and that's because in nearly half of
economies that the oecd tracks fewer
than 10% of people over the age of 65
still work that is not going to fly in a
resilient world but in a resilient World
we've rethought what work looks like at
older ages and we strategically leverage
technology to maximize our productivity
and we can work longer because we're
healthier in a resilient world we
finally realize that investing in health
is a much better use of time and
resources than trying to dictate
population size
similarly in a resilient World we've put
in place policies incentives and
technologies that recognize how we
consume is just as important as how many
of us consume and the environment is
healing in a resilient World those
societies closer to the start of this
demographic transition take advantage of
the time to plan and Institute
sustainable systems in the face of their
demographic change this is important
because for the population age of 60
plus to go from 15% of the total to 30%
it'll take Ireland 92 years the United
Kingdom 89 years and Germany 70 years
for that same demographic shift to
happen now it'll take India 34 years
Mexico 32 Iran 20 and Thailand only 19
it's happening faster now we really need
to realize this because those countries
have to act including sweets of policies
like moving away from informal economies
that increase the risk of poverty in
older
ages you know there are so many people
on the planet right now just between the
ages of 65 and 74 that altogether they'd
be the third most populous country in
the world there's far more of them than
there are Global migrants which we don't
hear about right and there'll be 800
million of them by the middle of this
Century they're a vast untapped resource
in most places in the world right now
but a well utilized one in a resilient
world and to Mutual
benefit we should run from a fearful
world and get our heads out of the sand
and we should be able to imagine a much
better more resilient
world I've always thought that the way
we feel about population aging to a
large extent reflects the really
negative way we feel about our
individual aging and that bias has held
us back but just as with our own aging
this shift is inevitable so what are we
going to do about
it as individuals we know that our
actions now set us up to live longer
healthier more financially secure lives
ours our society's actions set us up for
one of these three worlds to become our
reality let's make it a resilient world
and reimagine a grayer smaller world as
a beautiful one thank you
yeah